[Music]
War should be the absolute last option
unfortunately we seem to take it as like
door number two or three we can defeat
any military in the world in a conflict
there's there's no doubt about it we
just have Superior technology we have
Superior training it's not going to be
easy that's the part that we trip up on
and what are we willing to sacrifice for
victory if you're going to war you have
to have the will the will to kill and
the will to die and when you say the
will to kill what's hard about that is
you don't just kill the enemy when you
go to war civilians get killed too and
so you have to have the will to do that
you don't intentionally do it but you
have to recognize that that is going to
happen and then you have to have the
will to die which means no matter how
good you are you're going to lose troops
if you've been following me a while you
know that I've been drinking ag1 all
year no matter where I go or what I do
if I'm at the racetrack if I'm in Europe
for 6 weeks no matter what I'm drinking
ag1 every single morning when I started
drinking ag1 daily what I noticed was
that my gut health improved I could eat
so many different foods without it
bothering me my skin has gotten better
my hair is healthier so many functions
that everybody wants to get better got
better it's so awesome and I've been
bragging about it so much that my
friends and my family have also started
t it and they love it as well ag1 is the
supplement that I trust to support my
body's daily needs and that's why we'
have been partners for so long if you
want to take ownership of your health it
starts with ag1 try ag1 and get a free
one-ear supply of vitamin D3 K2 plus
five free ag1 travel packs with your
first purchase go to drink a1.com pretty
intense that's drink a1.com
pretty intense check it out okay so I
met you at the CrossFit Games and I was
very excited when uh you sponsored it
because I thought maybe Joo will be
there and I want to meet him and then we
were there for a few days uh my sister
loves it and so I didn't know if you
were going to come and I thought that'd
be totally understandable you're
sponsoring it but then I'd heard that
you were there they're like oh there's
jao and I thought oh my God I want to
meet him we had just a really fun like
15 or so minute conversation before you
had to carry on one of the things that
we first started talking about that I'm
most fascinated with is because I I I
love to help and be inspiring but
sometimes it's hard to know how to be
inspiring if it's in you and so what we
were talking about is I was like how do
you if it's just in you how do you learn
how to teach it how do you inspire
people like where is that important to
you in
general when I go through my life when I
interact with other people I don't
really think in terms of hey I'm going
to try and Inspire this person that's
not really something that I'm thinking
about I think it's a a byproduct
of being around other people and when
you when when someone meets you when I
meet when I meet you and you're talking
to me about what you did when you were
16 years old and 20 years old and you
did this it's like oh that I'm learning
about you but I'm also there's a
byproduct of thinking hey this girl
stepped out in this whole other world
that's pretty inspiring so I don't think
of it as a proactive thing that I'm
actively trying to do if it's happening
it's more of like I I suppose a
collateral a collateral result of just
interacting with people it's not
something that I'm consciously yeah
trying to do now listen if I was talking
to when I was a seal platoon commander
and I was talking to my guys even then I
wasn't thinking like oh I'm going to try
and Inspire these guys to do this thing
thing but what you're saying is hey this
is what we got to get done this is how
we're going to do it this is why it's
important and I think those things can
definitely be inspiring at
times what is it about being able to
lead that team to be able to inspire
them if you're the platoon needed that
what is it about you that you've
realized gives you that skill set so
growing up in the military right I grew
up I joined when I was 18 years old and
I was observant so I was wasn't the
fastest guy I wasn't the smartest guy I
wasn't the strongest guy I wasn't the
best shot so I always knew that what I
was going to be able to deliver wasn't
going to be one of those things right so
I was paying attention to like what my
leadership was doing how they were
interacting what they were doing from a
planning perspective how they were
thinking about problems that we were
going to have to overcome and so I was
paying attention to that stuff sure I
was paying attention to try and be a
better shot and try and be stronger and
try to be faster my my talents were
limited in that area so what could I do
I knew I could figure things out I knew
I could communicate and I paid attention
I would say it started from me just
paying attention to the people in
leadership positions and thinking to
myself oh yeah when when this guy said
that thing that made sense when this
other guy said this other thing it
didn't make sense when this guy was
humble and treated us with respect it
made us really want to support and help
him when this person was arrogant or
treated us like we were below him that
really made us not like that leader so I
paid attention to that stuff and over
time you know learned some
lessons you mentioned problem solving
and I would imagine that's something
that you know you obviously do that at a
very high level you need to do that in
really critical situations so how do you
teach problem solving now and what was
it that you learned that you know what
is the formula for problem solving yeah
so there's a couple key
components first of all the way you get
it better at problem solving is by
problem solving now I can't throw an
ultra complex problem at you if you have
don't have any experience problem
solving I've got to give you like a
smaller problem and let you figure out
how to solve that smaller problem and
then I'll give you a little bit more
complex one a little bit more complex
one a little bit more comp complex one
over time but here's what you are going
to learn and this is what we are trying
to teach is the solution to the problem
is very difficult to see from inside the
problem it's very difficult to see what
the problem is from inside the problem
so what we teach and what I teach is to
is for people to remove themselves from
the problem so they can see the whole
picture from the outside we call it
Detachment so detaching yourself from
the problem so that you can see more
broadly what's happening and from there
you'll find a solution it's like in your
life when you're having some problem and
then you're like I don't know what to do
and so you go for a run and in the
middle of that run you're like oh here's
how I should solve that yeah just a
little space sleep on it yeah sleep on
it or there's some problem that your
team is involved in and you don't know
you know you've been at lunch and when
you come back you look at the problem
for four seconds you're like hey change
this and they go oh oh okay it's because
you weren't all in the involved and
surrounded by the problem so teaching
people to take a step back take a breath
look around that's how you become a big
a good Problem Solver with one more
component which is having an open mind M
opening up your mind because if you
already think you know how to solve the
problem you're not going to be looking
for a solution and you're going to keep
trying the same solution which isn't
working and that's why you're having a
problem in the first place yeah so
detaching taking a step back and having
an open mind for whatever solution can
come yeah is the way that I teach and
that's what I taught in the SEAL Teams
and that's what I teach now what
personality traits lead someone to not
being open-minded ego having a big
ego um when you have a big ego it just
shuts out everything right so now all of
a sudden if I have a big ego and I'm
looking at a problem I already think I
know the solution so and not only that
I'm not listening to you so when you're
trying to tell me hey jonco it seems
like this is the thing I might be like
she doesn't know what she's talking
about because my my ego is too big I
think I'm smarter than you I think I'm
better than you so I'm not listening to
what you say so having a big ego is the
primary problem that we have to overcome
to get people to figure out Solutions do
you think that you can take someone with
a big ego though and get them
to dampen it and temper it you do
because it seems like one of those
things that if you have a big ego you're
not willing to even go the to the place
that says so what is it that gets
someone with a big ego to get in check
and put themselves in a more humble
open-minded state so there's like a
Tipping Point there's like a critical
point where if someone is beyond this
critical point with their ego you're
right like they can't be saved they're
narcissist they literally can't be saved
and this is when we would fire someone
in the SEAL Teams from a leadership
position they would be in that zone
where you'd say hey the way you ran that
operation that plan you didn't think
through that plan and their immediate
response is oh yes I did it's just that
the weather was bad or we didn't expect
this or my new guys are Yep they're just
pointing fingers so those guys they're
they're they're going to get fired okay
and it doesn't happen very often because
most people aren't full on in the fullon
ego category where they can't be saved
right most of the time like oh the guy's
got a big ego and you're like hey man
the way you guys hit that Target was a
bad call and they
go what do you think I should have done
like they they at least go yeah I could
have done better and as long as you get
that as long as they can just have a
little bit of humility in there you can
probably bring them back now one of the
ways that I used to take someone that
has a big ego and and get a little
humility is I would put them in charge
of a training operation that I knew that
they weren't going to be able to handle
and so then you know I say okay Danica
here's the mission you're gonna go out
and hit this Target and you're like oh I
got it no problem you're all cocky and
arrogant and then you go out you hit the
target everything goes to [__] and you
come back and I said hey how was that
you're like I I need some help you know
what I mean and then all of a sudden we
can talk and I can say hey here's what
you need to think about in your mission
planning here's the way you should
utilize this weapons asset so so you
start small with something that they
have to concede to yes yes it's that
like two to three% harder every time I
think it's uh is that from um James
clear right it's from his book like it
just something needs to be like two to
3% harder than it was to keep someone
involved and not overwhelm them so if
you have a lack of confidence and you
know I'm like hey Danica I want you to
run this Mission you're like I don't
really think I can do it like I I I
don't think I have the experience then I
might say okay here's a little part of
the mission hey can you run this small
thing and you go I I can do that and
it's something that I know you're
confident and capable of doing so you go
out and you do it your confidence goes
up Y and so I build your confidence up
with a bunch of small little missions
and then each one gets a little bit
bigger and a little bit broader the next
thing you know you're running big
complex operations as the Ground Force
Commander which is what we want as
opposed to someone that's got a big ego
and thinks they're doing everything
perfect I'm GNA give them something
that's they can't do well and it kind of
they get stung and now they come back
and they got their tail between their
legs like hey I need some help with this
hopefully rare case you get someone
that's like well it just was a stupid
Mission like we wouldn't do this in real
life and it's like okay and so you try
and talk to him like Hey actually
everyone's done that mission or this is
a standard training mission that we do
it's just that your platoon didn't do
good on it so you have to talk them
through and hopefully you can get them
to just be a little bit humble in which
case you're going to be okay how much
does the like community of the the the
guys around play in it and like how much
is it just the leader versus the whole
entire the whole entire operation with
everybody do other people play a big
role
totally and once again if you're the
leader and you're like an an okay leader
maybe you're even not the best leader
but you're humble you're gonna be fine
because you got some guys in your
platoon look in a seal platoon there's
some studs in there they can handle
anything they can make it happen and
they'll be like hey Danica here's what
we should do and you'll be like okay
sounds good and you just kind of let let
the team run it because you are humble
enough to know that you don't know
everything where we have a problem is
you're a bad leader and someone on your
team says Hey Danica this doesn't make
sense and you're like Hey we're doing it
my way and now you're G to execute a
mission that's not effective plan and
you're going to fail so as long as you
have a a leader that's humble enough to
listen yeah there's going to be some
people I'm talking in a seal plon but
this is true in most cases there's going
to be some people on the team that are
like hey here's what we should do here's
how we can step up but leadership is the
most important thing it's the most
important thing on the battlefield in
business and life but in a seal platoon
you don't need the actual leader to be
the best leader in the world you don't
need the platoon Chief to be the best
leader in the world you need you need a
leader someone someone in there has to
be able to step up and Lead as long as
you have that you're going to be fine if
there's literally no leadership or you
have actual bad leadership which
generally is defined by
someone that's egotistical because
listen if you're let's say you're not
tactically sound meaning you don't
really know what the best moves to make
or you're
indecisive or you're just weak or you
can't project your plan or you can't
simplify there's all kinds of problems
that you could have as a leader but as
long as you're humble enough to be like
Hey listen I I'm not that good at coming
up with plan but Fred over here he makes
good plans hey Fred what do you think we
should do as long as you're humble we'll
get the job done yeah yeah but when
you're arrogant everything's off the
table which leads me to say asking for
sort of a characterization of what a
good leader is what characteristics
would you call being the most important
elements to going this is a good leader
as you can probably guess humility is
the most important right characteristic
for a leader that to me is number one
for me number two and it's kind of hand
inand but is having an open mind and
being able to receive information yeah
there's times where arrogant
people get
intelligence get reports that they go oh
that can't be right now look is there is
all intelligence 100% correct no
absolutely not are all reports 100%
right no but to just be like oh that
report's not right I people do that in
business right the the the product won't
be
selling and the team will come in and
say hey it looks like this product isn't
moving maybe we kind of we need need to
make some adjustments and the response
is no the products it's going to people
just don't get it yet right right right
oh so the whole Market
the consumer is wrong but you're right
so if we're not humble and we don't have
an open mind we're going to have
problems so those to me are the most
important characteristics of leadership
and then what you get is a bunch of
other little components that play some
part like being articulate of course
it's important for a leader to be
articulate but if I'm in a leadership
position and I'm not very articulate but
you're on my team and you are guess what
I'll be like hey an can you tell the
team what's happening and you go yeah I
got it and you're super articulate and
you communicate so some self- awareness
might be a really helpful one too
self-awareness which also requires
humility to be like Oh I'm I'm not good
at this Dan is so that's what I'm G to
do right right is there a healthy amount
of ego like is there's a it's sort of an
idea that in business there's so many
narcissists that run companies and they
they build these big companies and you
know that's sort of what I think about
when you say like this person can't come
back they can't at all take
accountability they kind of fall more in
that end of the spectrum where they're
not able to to do it like what is a
healthy ego look like and is there a
certain amount of that that actually is
a really big positive for a leader 100%
And we already talked about it a little
bit which is oh Danica doesn't believe
she's capable of doing this job you're
you're you're humble to a point where
you lack ego to where you don't have any
confidence so I don't want someone in a
leadership position that's like I'm not
sure if I can do this right we don't we
don't want that person on the
team not that we don't want them on the
team but we don't want them in a
leadership position so yes and I think
what good healthy it's a balance right I
wrote the book The dichotomy of
leadership it's like a good balance
between being arrogant and being humble
what does that leave you leaves you
confident just a good confident person
actually I'd be interested to talk to
you about this I somebody asked me about
doing stressful things and like what is
my protocol for doing stressful things
and I kind of talked through my protocol
and I realized something this was only
like two months ago on my podcast I
talked about the fact that I went
through the protocol I was like okay so
what do I do well obviously I train very
hard I prepare I rehearse I think
through the way things are going to go I
think about what the outcomes are and
then this is the part that I added to my
whole
thing and I realize this is something
I've done my whole
life right before the moment of
execution
like right before five seconds five
minutes but before the moment of
execution I get a little bit cocky just
a little bit cocky so what does that
mean for instance we're going on an
operation I've been thinking like okay
we've trained we've prepared we've
rehearsed we came up with a good plan
you know we we've done everything we can
when I get my gear on and put my night
vision goggles down
we're GNA kick some ass like we're GNA
win yeah yeah uh archery I do archery
and you're you're going you know you you
have to practice so how do you how do
you do well in archery what's your
protocol it's a stressful thing shooting
at a target shooting at an animal if
you're hunting it's a stressful thing so
what do you do well train
prepare go go do rehearsals visualize
what it's gonna be do all those things
right but for me one key component is
like when I am going to take shot what
goes through my mind is like oh I'm
gonna I'm G to Bullseye this shot right
now like that's what's happen to you
have to you have to it's like have you
ever played golf I no golf always seems
like the first one like you stand over
the ball and you have like you could
have 20 thoughts you know and one of
them could be many times could be like
what am I doing and then you swing and
of course you have a horrible or like
this isn't going to be good of course
you have a horrible shot but then if you
go I'm going to drill this or even make
a joke be like guys watch this I'm going
to I'm going to like I'm I'm gonna nail
it it's going on the green and you like
you you can really talk yourself into it
so like that's an interesting spot with
ego is that how many times do you think
that you can convince the platoon of
something that they don't believe
because you do like your ego or
arrogance or confidence right there like
gets it over the goal line for everyone
else that they can they siphon your
confidence off of you that they they
they they then believe something that
they wouldn't wouldn't otherwise have
you ever had experiences like that when
we talk about belief for me and I had to
Define this to explain what I meant by
this
because making sure that people believe
in what they're doing and believing that
they can accomplish it is absolutely
critical but to me belief isn't like uh
if you believe it you can achieve it and
if I read was like oh y if you believe
it you can achieve it that doesn't get
at least not a seal tune and most high
performing teams you're not going to be
able to convince them of something
that's not believable what for me what
belief is showing people that there's an
actual Pathway to Victory There's an
actual way of achieving this it's like
hey guys this is going to be a really
hard Mission but if we do this they go
and we do this and we do this yep we'll
get here yes we will and that will bring
us here yes and as long as you can show
people
this is where we are this is what the
actual Pathway to Victory looks like
that's what belief is to me so belief
isn't just some kind of hollow word like
if you can believe it you can achieve it
yeah you've got to actually show people
the Pathway to Victory and the
challenges you've got to show what those
challenges are and that it's possible to
overcome them and here's how and that's
to me what belief is like you took them
on a road map of 2 to 3% each step and
so you really took them like 40% but you
showed them Pro evidence by proof that
there is a pathway to it yep we do this
in the business World a lot right you
know for me to go in and like our goal
is our goal is to do $100 million this
year and people go well if you just roll
in there and say that people go you know
that sounds farfetched but if you say
Hey listen I've broke it down by all our
all the lines of operation what do you
guys think we could do this oh yeah we
could do this what about this section
what about this product about what about
this service and all of a sudden people
start adding up those numbers does
anyone not think we can do 18 million
with this thing and they're like no they
yeah we can because we already have this
client we get one more client that's
gonna okay and people all of a sudden
put it together and everyone nods their
head and says yeah we they believe it ah
what have you realized about yourself in
hindsight too about just your ability to
problem solve like ability to lay out a
road map most people it's a total
weakness I have ideas for companies I
have tons of them and some as we talked
about before some of them are bad um but
I have no I can't do the road map that's
not like I don't do details I don't know
how it's gonna happen I've got some
dream but I don't know how to make it
happen so where did you learn that you
like what have you what did you learn
about yourself that made you capable of
laying this road map out and then how do
you teach a road map to
someone I do something that I call the
iterative decision making process sounds
fancy but all it really is is and and so
I was kind of known in the SE teams as
being a div decisive person meaning like
oh I'm gonna make
decisions but I kind of cheated kind of
cheated the whole time because what I
would actually do is in if there was a
problem on the battlefield there's a
problem instead of me trying to make a
big giant call that's gonna solve that
problem with one swift
move which take which is really hard to
figure out really hard to predict and
there's a lot of variables that you
can't account for yeah instead of trying
to solve everything with one big move I
would just take one small step so my
decision would be very fast hey we're
going to move to the next building look
there's a there's a building that has
enemy in it and it's four blocks away
and we're taking fire from them I just
don't say all right attack that building
because we don't know what's actually
there we don't know how many enemy there
is but you have to make a decision so my
decision would be hey everyone move to
the next North building it's very small
decision we're just moving one building
30 yards but you're going to collect do
we're going to get more information once
I get that next piece of information I'm
gonna make another small decision and
you can do this in business as well oh
wow so if you want to start making
supplements which like I started making
supplements I didn't come out with a
line of
supplements I started with a supplement
to see if there was a market for that
supplement and if people appreciated
having stuff that was very clean and
very eable and I wanted to make sure
that people wanted to pay for that and
it's like okay so we made one yep yep
definitely people like it okay well
let's make another one and we continued
that down the path same thing with
clothing make clothing make clothing
made in America to me I love the idea of
buying American-made clothing yeah it's
very difficult to do it's very difficult
to make things expensive can be
expensive so well did we go out and you
know buy multiple factories no we
started with one little tiny Factory and
guess what we started making a couple
little products and as people bought
those products it was like okay we can
add another product to the product line
yep oh people definitely want that too
what about jeans everyone in America
wears let's start making jeans so to me
that's the way I do the problem solving
is I take small iterative steps first of
all not in the problem like I said
earlier but then I take small iterative
steps
keep moving in the right direction and
by the way I'm humble enough that if I
get feedback yeah we made this one
supplement and no one likes it and they
don't care and they'd rather just get a
cheaper product that's not quite as good
for them that's what the market is okay
well I went in the wrong direction and I
I didn't
[Music]
overinvestment you can ciss that money
goodbye but we make 200 Pairs and
they're sold out very quickly okay let's
make 400 pairs next time and so that's
that's what I do do but I have to remain
humble enough to actually listen to the
feedback that you get because sometimes
we make a product that doesn't land
right and people are like they don't buy
it cool I don't say no they just don't
understand it no I don't understand the
market did you make mistakes early in
your life where you went too far too
fast and learned the lesson is this
inherent within you or was there at some
point in time where you go okay I don't
need to jump in the deep end okay we
don't need to do this this is a better
approach you know slow and steady wins
the race yeah you're never slow and
steady but but taking it one step at a
time in this patient fashion is actually
the fastest way yep it is actually the
fastest way and for me there there's not
a whole bunch of like Eureka moments in
my life where I was like oh my gosh I
need changed the way I think for me it
was look I was in the seal teams joined
when I was 18 years old when you're a
new guy in the SEAL Teams you're not in
charge of anything like you're in charge
of like a piece of rope like hey make
sure we have rope to tie the boats off
I'm like okay I got the Rope I got the
Rope like that's what you're in charge
of but I was watching and I was
observing and so I got to see oh my boss
just like committed all of us to assault
this target without leaving any reserve
behind how' that work out not very well
that doesn't seem like a good idea so
just overtime I paid attention to it and
and I I bet there's something to do
with taking risk but also doing a risk
assessment and saying yeah we take risks
but we do it in a in a manner where
we're not overleveraging or we're not
putting ourselves in a situation where
we're going to lose Leverage
that's one thing I an
underlying an underlying sort of theme
in my life is I don't want to give you
or the enemy or the market or the
bankers leverage to the point where I
don't have a a way out I don't have some
kind of control look I'll take risk but
I'm not going to put myself in a
situation or I'm going to try as hard as
I can not to put myself in a situation
where I'm
stuck oh so there's always a way out
you're always making sure there's a way
out there's like a there's like a
there's a pathway to Freedom somehow
some way it's a contingency planning
right it's contingency planning we're
not going to go and do this where I
can't get out of this situation and so I
think that means taking smaller steps so
that I don't end up you know borrowing
money to build a factory that to make
jeans that no one wants to buy we going
broke and be like started all over that
was stupid this this humility thing I
find to be uh it seems to
be basically at the foundation of a lot
of this is your ability the open
open-mindedness and humility kind of go
hand in hand so where did that come from
again I feel like so much is like in you
but I'm trying to figure out like all of
this is like how do we help other people
have these values and so how did you
learn it and how did you teach it
essentially so is humility from being in
the atmosphere of being around military
around seals around is it just that and
if it's just that then what are those
values and if not is it a lesson that
was learned is it the way you were were
were raised with certain values in the
house were there certain certain rules
you had about making your bed or or what
were those things that make you have so
much humility and open-mindedness that
you can do these jobs uh that are to do
this job at all so like I said it wasn't
a Eureka moment but there's absolutely a
scenario that I went through I wrote
about it in this book called leadership
strategy and tactics Field Manual I was
in a seal
platoon and it was my second steel
platoon so I had a little bit of
experience and we had a good Core group
of guys everyone was
solid except for the guy that was in
charge of the platoon and and he was
everything that I just talked about like
hey the one thing you can't have is
someone that's super arrogant super
egotistical he was that guy he didn't
listen to anybody else he imposed his
plan on
us he it was his way or the
highway and it was bad and so because he
only has one brain and he's trying to
come up with a complex plan to conduct a
training operation and this is in the
90s there's no war going on but we're
cond training
operations he doesn't have the ability
the cognitive ability no one does to
create an entire plan by himself but
that's what he was trying to do so Us in
the platoon were saying Hey sir we
should do this no we don't need to do
that Hey sir we might want to come over
here no we don't we're doing it my way
and that's how he was wasn't listening
to anybody else totally arrogant and
quite frankly he also was pretty
demeaning when he talked to some of the
guys in Ni platoon he kind of walked
around totally insecure yeah
and there's a whole backstory on why he
was like that primarily was because he
didn't have much experience so in order
to make up for his lack of experience he
walked around thinking and trying to act
like he knew everything to make a to
make a long story short we ended up
having a mutiny in that platoon and we
went within the within the platoon or
with him with him we went above his head
in the chain of command and told his
boss that we didn't want to work for
this guy anymore is this not is this a
taboo thing to do totally taboo totally
taboo like the worst thing you can do in
the military is like to have a mutiny in
fact the punishment for Mutiny is death
like Mutiny is not allowed now look we
weren't going to get executed but
because this was in the 90s and it was
just we went and said hey this guy's
arrogant he doesn't listen to us and it
sucks to work for him and that guy ended
up getting fired and when that guy so
when that guy got fired a guy came in to
take his place and the guy that came in
to take his place was this legendary
seal oh and I didn't know him no one no
no one in the platoon actually knew him
but we all knew his name wow we all knew
this guy he had combat experience he'd
come up through the ranks W he'd gone
all the way up on the enlisted side to
being almost the top of the enlisted
side of the chain of command and then he
came back and be became an officer and
he was working his way through that just
legendary guy
and the first time I saw this guy we
were waiting we were told hey you're
getting this guy to take over your OPP
we're all kind of like oh hell yeah and
then I was kind of like hey guys they're
doing this because they want him to come
in here and like smash us cuz we're the
mutineers we're the MERS they're bring
they like they didn't kill you all but
they're going kill you all and so I'm
thinking oh we're screwed like we got
this badass guy coming in that's G to
take our lunch money man and so I'm
standing there we had a a little quanson
Hut little like a like a Contractor
trailer like
in one of those that's our area and
we're waiting he's coming in after lunch
so it's like 1:00 we're supposed to be
in there waiting and I'm like the first
time you're meeting first time I'm
meeting him I'm literally looking out
the window like waiting for him to come
there's little curtains on the Windows
I'm looking and like one guy comes out
another guy comes out fin guy comes out
and he's kind of walking towards us and
I'm like is this him I go no this can't
be him because you don't know what he
looks like looks like just know his name
but I'm looking I'm like this could this
be him I'm like no the guy looked kind
of like small and I'm kind of like this
this can't be this legendary guy you
know he keeps coming smell's not bad
smell's not bad but you know you have in
your mind of what this guy's going to be
like so I'm oh this can't be him he's
this kind of skinny guy kind of small
looking no can't be him keeps coming
gets closer I'm like this definitely
can't be him because this this guy's old
wonder why he's a legend you know I this
guy's
old he looks like he's probably at least
35 years old which to me at the time was
like the oldest person I've ever seen in
my life and he walks in me and he
he says Hey guys sorry to hear about
what happened with your last boss but
I'm not worried about it I'm just
looking forward to working with you all
now totally humble wants to work with us
you know he's not like I'm the commander
now or I heard about what happened and
there's a new sheriff in town none of
that just I'm looking forward to working
with you guys that afternoon he's
cleaning out the garbage sweeping up the
platoon space and taking out the garbage
himself that was like a job for the
lowliest new guy that was in trouble and
here he is doing it and to make this guy
that's the way he was the the most
experienced guy the senior guy and the
most humble guy and what I got to see at
that young age was the difference
between someone that's arrogant and
someone that's humble and someone that
doesn't respect treats people without
respect and someone that treats people
with respect and someone that doesn't
trust the team and someone that trusts
the
team and someone that doesn't listen to
anything we say and someone that listens
to what we say so I took all of that
from that guy and I don't know if I
would have seen it so clearly if we
hadn't have had the Arrogant guy first
you had contrast you had a Delta
contrast and so because of all that I
mean we love this guy to this guy to
this day that's the guy I'm trying to
imitate that's the guy I'm trying to
emulate wow and everybody that ever
works for him they that's how they feel
and so that's what I always tried to do
and I never did it as good as him
because he was just like the best
but that's what I try to do so when you
ask me where that came from that's where
it came from wow did he just purely lead
by example or was there actually some
kind of education and learning process
if you want to emulate
that essentially there might be
questions was he able to articulate it
or was it just purely lead by example
pure example wow and that's like so much
of what you do never talked about it's
your 4:30 a.m. watch this example never
he never actually talked to us about
leadership what never never talk to us
about leadership never sat down and said
hey here's what you should watch out for
it was all example and
osmosis yeah that that's like something
to dig into because it's Unique because
there's so many books on leadership
right and it's like very hard so it's
more about like the puzzle pieces of
what how you act that make you a great
leader and then you end up getting
called a leader so is the only way that
you can learn how to be a leader is to
be around someone that's a great leader
no because I learned a lot from the bad
leader and he's not the only bad leader
that I learned from I learned so much
from leaders where I'd say I'm not gonna
act like that I was perhaps I can get an
iota of credit for having the
introspectiveness to say why don't I
like this guy oh it's because he treats
everyone like we don't know anything or
he doesn't listen to us or he doesn't
trust us or he doesn't respect us oh I
was at least aware enough to realize to
ask myself why do why do we hate this
guy because we hated him why do we hate
this guy oh it's because he acts like
this and then six months later why do we
love this guy oh he listens to us oh he
treats us with respect oh he is
influenced by us H yeah and so he's
humble enough to be influenced by us and
we are he is our Superior yes which
leads me to ownership being you know
foundational right so where did you
learn the hard way in any way with
ownership was there a point in time when
you were ever cocky was there a point in
time you ever pointed the finger more so
that you thought oh oh it's a lot easier
or did because some it's just this
wonderful Paradox in life of it's
actually in your true honesty that you
get someone to trust you even if you
like say something that you did wrong or
say something negative even like cuz
then they can trust that when you say
something else that's positive or good
that they believe you like there's so
much in honesty so what's your what's
the relationship with with ownership and
how did that become something that you
were so good at and and and could could
then lead the way with that it's
something that is
embedded Unwritten not always
followed and yet always known inside the
SEAL Teams
so you are you know shooting at a Target
and you missed the Target and I say hey
Danica what happened on that shot and
you go
oh my my scope was set
wrong as soon as you say that everybody
kind of knows that you just blamed your
scope for your shot right the wind the
whatever yeah the wind the whatever it's
like there's always excuses to make and
it's like I said this wasn't like talked
about no one said they might say like oh
it's it's not the shooter or it's not
the not the equipment it's a shooter
like someone might say that to you like
it's not the Archer it's the arrow it's
not the arrow it's the Archer type thing
they might say that too but it's not
like it wasn't like
a foundational thing that got taught to
you in like hey here's here's a list of
things you need think about wasn't like
that it was always an under curring
undercurrent theme of of how to behave
so was it one of those things where if
they if you did say like it was the
scope they'd go you know uh they'd come
out with some something simple like
you're in charge of the scope yes so so
it implied in every correction they
would always turn it back on you because
I mean when you're out there in battle
like you can't I mean you need to be
freaking accountable but I don't want to
make it sound as if it was this Mantra
within the sealed because it wasn't it
was mindset it was an underlying thing
that not everybody did huh oh you know
who did it the guy that was humble when
our platoon messed up you know what he
said hey I should have done a better job
overseeing when the Arrogant guy messed
up you know what he said you guys should
have done this better so again I learned
so many lessons from that contrast and
part of that thing
was that taking ownership
is infinitely Superior than placing
blame on other people and and I had
another funny thing that happened to me
I was going through basic SEAL
training and I went on we have a timed
swim so it's like a two- mile timed
ocean swim when you're swimming out in
the middle of the ocean someone has to
do that makes me nervous someone has to
do what's called The Guiding we call it
guiding but it's basically the
navigation sure so and we would trade
off navigation so I might be navigating
for a while which means a little bit
extra work for me or maybe it's cuz I'm
the one that's facing the beach and and
then you do it for a while and then I do
it for a while then you do it for a
while and I and you're both swimming
you're both swimming you literally have
to do the two miles yourself you're
doing the two miles yourself yeah yeah
you're swimming two miles but the person
that's guiding usually is a little bit
ahead like one foot ahead and just kind
of peeking out and seeing where you're
going okay and when you don't guide well
you go a little too far this way a
little too far that way so you end up
swimming a lot further than you needed
to right so my swim bud and I we fail
this
swim and we fail this swim
and I knew that I was pretty decent at
guiding and he wasn't great he wasn't
awful but he wasn't a very fast
swimmer so we go to the instructors
afterwards you know everyone that failed
to swim had to go and report to the
first phase instructors and explain why
you failed to
swim and so we go in there you know it's
getting called in Pair by pair so my
pair with this other guy we get called
in and the instructor looks up and like
all right what happened and without
missing a beat my swim Buddy goes
willink can't guide well and I was kind
of like oh dang just got thrown on the
bus here and what happened was again
Unwritten Unwritten rule the instructors
were like oh it's his fault huh they
kind of jumped on him on him a little
bit because they knew that he was just
blaming me I mean again an Unwritten
Rule and again if that's even if that's
true what did you do to help it like why
didn't if willing bad a guiding why
didn't you guide because then you could
pass the swim so they kind of jumped on
him and that was there's a thousand
things like this that happened in my
career in the first year two years where
I saw people get in trouble for not
taking ownership no no those people
didn't say you need to take ownership
they didn't say that yeah I also got to
see you know people that did that blamed
someone else and you just think man that
just sounds terrible I do not ever want
to be that guy and so that's kind of
over time you just build up this build
up this this habit really of when
there's something wrong looking at
myself first and seeing what I did wrong
what were your parents
like my parents were kind of normal my
dad was a school teacher my mom was a
school teacher so my dad taught history
and sociology and my mom taught English
and personality wise were they hard was
your were they disciplinary were they
easygoing were they
optimistic I was a lot as a kid I had a
lot of energy I had a lot of yeah energy
is like the nicest way of saying it I
know the feeling I know why you make
these and when I asked you how many is
safe to drink and you said four I went
oh my God I would vibrate off the planet
I'm working on number two and I might be
levitating by the end of this interview
yeah so my parents
were you know I was a lot was a lot to
handle and I think they just kind of
kind of were like hey let's just hope he
lives and and let him go and that was it
you know and then as soon as I could I
joined the Navy and and got out of there
but you know my my parents weren't some
you know people probably think my dad
would be like uh the great Santini you
know that movie The Great Santini is
like the the Marine Corps dad his kids
you know everyone thinks that that's
what and they also think that that's
what I would be like as a dad oh that's
what we're going next yeah but the
reality is
that's just like you might think that
that's how I would be the platoon but
I'm not like that there's what I am is
open-minded listen to what the platoon
has to say actually what I really want
is if you're in my platoon I want you to
run the mission I don't want even have
to run it I want you to be able to step
up and do it why because that means you
don't need me why is that good because
because then if I get shot or killed or
you're out there on your own you can
handle it you're good I want to develop
you into a leader so you don't need me
anymore that's the whole goal and that
is the goal with the kids too right do I
want to make my kids have to listen to
everything that I say because they don't
know how to use their own judgment no
that's terrible I want them to be able
to say oh yeah you don't need to worry
about me I'll like I didn't have curfews
with my
kids interesting yeah how did it go
awesome why because you put the fear of
God in them or I think no I put values
into them like like don't do dumb
stuff when I was a kid and racing my dad
was
like if you get a DUI or if you get drug
tested and fail you can't race anymore
he would tell me this as a teenager like
14 15 16 17 is it not true not true
plenty of people drove without their
license and we didn't get Dr drug tested
till Indie cart that took a long time to
get to like that was not true but it put
the fear of god in me that if I did
those things that I would get in trouble
so I just didn't yeah now I'm not saying
I didn't have conversations that were
like hey when if you're drinking like
terrible things happen and you can make
mistakes when you're drunk that change
the rest of your life yeah and by the
way that's true yeah so it's a little
bit of fear God too yeah so like I had
those kind of ations with them but you
know we're going to a party
okay have fun don't do anything stupid
we it's to a point where I can't even
did you hold a gun or like you I can't
even explain to you like I said well
what time are you GNA be home and don't
worry about it because we didn't have
those conversations it would just be
like yeah don't do anything what time
would they come home then sometimes they
come home at 11: Sometimes they come
home at
2 yeah I'm interested how we're in this
uh is this a hard times create strong
men strong men create good times good
times create weak men and weak men uh
create hard times and so like where are
we in that
loop I I mean the general consensus
right now is that we're in good times
processing of creating weak men right
that's where you know it's kind of the
you're not a weak man so I I I I want
this to be like a like a playlist for
like young men and I and I do want to
make it more specific to men what we do
about that like where do where what is
wrong in society that there is so many
mental health issues that there is so
many um so many uh you know school
shootings um and and a lot of these are
LED a lot a lot of these are are are
boys or men um where are we going wrong
in this situation
I mean we see men we see people that are
popular wearing dresses and pearls and
things like that and like it it's just
it has to be I I think to myself it must
be a really really really hard time to
be a guy right now to be a guy it must
be
confusing you know how to address a
woman even there's this hard hard
position of like am I going to get in
trouble do I can I come on to a woman
like can I flirt with her I don't envy
men right now and I and I'm curious
where how we navigate out of this and I
feel like you probably at least could
have some idea of when you watch this
happening in the world you think to
yourself
XYZ first of all I always want to start
off by saying when this conversation
comes up that even though these types of
men in this case are seen a lot in like
social media like even though they're
seen a lot wearing dresses or wearing
pearls or whatever else you said even
though they're seen a lot in social
media that's not overwhelming what
American men are like there's a small
percentage of men that I like I have a
leadership consulting company I travel
all over the world travel all over the
country for sure
and most people are out there working
hard they're out there trying to figure
out how to do better with their business
they're trying to figure out how they
can take care of their customers how
they can take care of their people like
that's what most people are doing most
people are not engaged in this whole
weird world that's happening out there
yeah they're so so so that's first of
all and I you know I have kids and the
kids my kids are young adult kids right
24 22 20 and I see who they hang around
with and they hang around with people
that are just like what we would
consider normal people that are out
there doing what they're doing the girls
and the boys the the young men and young
women they're they're being so because
of social media and because of the way
the algorithm works and because like
when you see or not you but when some
super conservative person sees someone
with a some guy that's wearing makeup
and he's like retweets it and that
person retweets it it's like it's you
see more of it right yeah and your
algorithm fills up with stuff cuz you
react to it so it gives you more of it
there's a whole reason that these things
are kind of coming to coming to
psychological attack with the algorithms
and the way that everything works that
could fill your feed with more of it
just because of one one moment right
it's not not a healthy representation of
the percentage thank you yes it's not a
healthy it's not a it's not a true right
representation of what it looks like in
the world now are there places that look
like that yes there are are there people
that are out there getting a little bit
crazy yes there are what is going to
bring us back I think that it's already
swinging back I think that people
already are like hey that's not going to
lead you to a good life if you behave in
this manner I think that the past few
years have been already bringing us back
in the other direction and probably one
of the first things you see when it
starts going back in the other direction
is a spike on social media of the the
weirdness right because people that are
starting to be like more normal are like
starting to retweet and repost things
that are outside of that so I think in
the past few years there's already we're
already starting to see the pendulum
come back and I think it will come back
and it'll be fine goes and Cycles so but
let's let's go little bit back and go
what does it mean to be
weak what does it mean to be yeah what
is weak instead of we saying like how do
we make a strong man let's just go all
the way back to like what is weak how
would you characterize someone weak yeah
I I
think people that are very wrapped up in
their emotions is is like a big one so
if I'm super emotional about things and
I'm allowing my emotions to drive my
decision-making process that's not going
to lead to good decisions and I'm being
weak because I'm
allowing my emotions and also
external variables to dictate the way
I'm going to act whereas someone that
has a
strong let's say a strong Spirit they'll
be like no I'm going to do what I'm
supposed to do I don't feel good today I
don't feel like doing this doesn't
matter I'm still going to do what I'm
supposed to do oh there's these
variables that are impacting my world
right now I'm not going to get emotional
I'm not going to freak out I'm going to
do what I'm supposed to do and I think
if that as a Cornerstone everything else
kind of falls into place because that
means you're doing the right things for
the right reasons that means you're
being disciplined with the way you're
operating your life and I think those
things will make strong men and women
now just a caveat this doesn't mean that
you ignore your emotions I'm not talking
about someone that's completely shut
down conundrum is for men these days
it's like we're being they're sort of
being asked to be more vulnerable um but
yet there's like vulnerability means
emotions and so there's this is like
sorting it out has to be hard for hard
for people yeah or you just say oh yeah
don't let your emotions drive your
decision- making but you still got to
put them in the calculus let's move on
who's freaking out about this you know
what I mean like really like who's
freaking out about this what's what's
the conundrum hey I saw on YouTube that
I should show my emotions more yeah but
don't act like a baby okay cool I can
understand that you know what I mean
like this isn't that complicated for you
it's not complicated you you this is the
this is the whole conversation it's like
you are these things and this is where
we started in in Madison when I talk
it's like how can how do you take
something that's really in you and learn
about it observe it and go oh I see the
pattern and this is how I can this is
how I can teach it to someone this is
how I can articulate it well enough and
and give someone a road map to to doing
it because um because not everyone's
going to have the luxury being being
able to meet you like this not
everyone's going to have the they're
going to read a book They're going to
see a video they're going to see a
YouTube they're going to see your
podcast but they don't get the time they
don't they don't get to watch you day in
and day out to live it to live the
leader but you just kind of answered
that question right
books podcasts interviews you before we
walked in here you were on the phone you
like oh he got a message from one of my
friends he's like you helped them a lot
yeah he says thanks or whatever like
something like that get a lot of
messages like that right yeah I've never
met that guy before yeah yeah I don't
know but guess what
he whatever whatever this particular
case was there's millions of them
stopped using drugs stopped drinking
started working out started training
Jiu-Jitsu started trying out my job I've
got millions of those so how do we help
people you show them the path you show
them the path and I think that's
probably why my podcast is very popular
my podcast is very popular because
people like oh I I'm in situation here
I'd like to do better I'm going to go to
this that's probably why Joe Rogan's
podcast is popular it's like oh you
should and and Joe Rogan doesn't say
don't drink or don't you know like have
fun I everyone have fun but he also
shows him getting in the cold plunge and
he shows discipline and he shows like
get sweat out the Heat and if I think
for a second that I'm having a hard time
I add 20 minutes you know like that's
the way it is so there's a whole that's
why I said like it's probably already
swinging back because you've already got
you know Jordan Peterson you know and
and going out and doing his Rogan's
another great example like people are
already swinging back in that direction
and I think that the generation that's
coming up right now is g to find that
because
because because it's the right thing to
do because it really is and this is what
I've noticed like you know I I I talk
about the pathway it's the like the path
of discipline having being on the right
path in
life you're going to end up
in a much better situation and the
further you go off the path the worse
your situation is going to become and
what happens is people go off the path
they don't work hard they don't work out
they don't eat well they drink they do
drugs and sure they do that for two
years and things aren't too bad but then
all a sudden like three years and maybe
they're not where they wanted to be four
years they're like this isn't working
and and and to have people out there
that are saying hey come back over here
get on this path right here work out
wake up the same time every day eat good
foods don't be getting drunk don't be
doing drugs like that kind of thing
right there this is how people text you
and say oh you're with Joo tell him
thanks like that's rad that's why
because the the more you stay on that
path of discipline in life the better
life you're going to have and it might
not feel like that all the time maybe
you want to go out partying tonight and
sleep in tomorrow and that feels good
for tonight and tomorrow maybe for just
tonight maybe tonight I went out but
tomorrow I already wake up and I'm
already like H you know I missed
Jiu-Jitsu class and I feel like crap you
already know that after one night you
know that yeah yeah but look I had a
blast last night and so when I'm 22
years old that kind of makes sense but
by the time you're 25 you're thinking
man this isn't working so I think what
you're what we are probably seeing right
now is people kind of wandering around
looking at the experimentation that they
can go look at what happened with the
hippies right in the 60s in the late 60s
like they went off the path they're
doing drugs they're doing free love all
this kind of crazy stuff and as they do
that eventually they go H this doesn't
this isn't really working right this
isn't really working and they come back
and they become you know by the time the
80s rolls around they become uh Wall
Street people yeah right what and and
then we have the '90s you know and so
what what is it about what personality
traits do you think people have that get
them to that that that make them lack
discipline lack accountability what is
it what is it what is it that they're
telling themselves in their inner
monologue what is going on in their head
that they go do they drink too much they
do too many drugs they don't show for
they don't put the effort in they they
lack essentially like Integrity right
like they know what is it yeah I one
thing that I always try and convey to
parents about their kids kids and kids
as we know can be anywhere between the
ages of like 1 and 29 maybe 32 right
that's kids right because we is that
they have a hard time connecting what
they're doing right
now and how that impacts the rest of
their life like when my dad told me
don't do drugs or don't get C drunk
driving or you won't be able to race so
I connected drinking and drugs with not
having the career I wanted he made the
connection for you yeah and it kept you
on the right path yeah so most people
don't make that Connection huh and they
say oh what ises it matter grades
they're they're thinking about what what
their grades in school are they're
thinking about hey I just want to pass
so I can move on to the next grade
that's it most but you know there's kids
in high school I know you didn't go to
high school but there's kids in high
school that from the time they get into
high school and they're in eighth grade
they're trying to get into the Ivy
League school so they're getting great
grades most kids aren't like that most
kids are like I don't know what I'm
going to do they don't connect that to
the Future marketing those ivy league
kids yeah guess what their parents were
their parents were like listen if you
don't get good grades right now you're
not going to get into a good school
you're going to be broke the rest of
your life so they they made that
connection the parents made the
connection for the kids in a lot of
cases look occasionally does a kid
figure out on their own yes but most of
the time they don't so a huge part of
what I try and convey to young kids is
what you're doing right now is going to
impact the rest of your life and that's
a that's a hard truth but man is it
helpful when people recognize that it's
that great saying of you're always
you're always one decision away from an
entirely different life yes indeed it's
scary one story that I told in this kids
book was about uh a friend of mine when
I was growing up a friend of mine named
Jeff and like we were best friends in
like third fourth fifth sixth grade and
then we kind of got separated a little
bit he started going down the path he
started like drinking doing drugs all
that stuff and I didn't but we were such
good friends that it never like hurt our
friendship we didn't we hang around as
much but but you drifted apart yeah we
drifted apart but we still had like a
core friendship that could never be
broken and so as we got older he got
more into drugs and I got kind of more
on a even more straight and narrow
path and finally I was going to the Navy
and when we were kids we would run
around in the woods with army camouflage
on and shoot each other with BB guns
with you like that's what we did so that
kind of like Warrior thing was in him by
the time where 18
he's like he he's not he's not coming
back kind of From the Path he's on he's
on drugs he's kind of dropped out of
school it's just all bad and I'm going
in the Navy and so the last time I
talked to him I was you know he said man
I heard you like going to go in the Navy
I heard you going in in try and to go in
the SEAL Teams and I was like yeah and
he's like I wish I could go with you and
I was like bro you can he's like no I
can't and like he knew that he had gone
too far
and this kid this guy
Jeff I I left for the Navy and he ended
up his girlfriend dumped him and he
killed
himself
and I when I told the story to the kids
I tell them hey you know he made
something decisions and he ended up
going to jail right that's kind of what
I told the kid story and when I but i r
told that same story on my podcast and I
told the adults what actually happened
and this was this the most horrible
thing about this is as I thought about
this I Googled him his name is Jeff Lang
I Googled him and there was
nothing like nothing like I Googled him
obituary or anything nothing couldn't
find an obituary couldn't find anything
nothing almost as if he never existed
and by the way he was a better athlete
than me he was funnier than me he was
smarter than me he was like a great
charismatic kid and this book right here
final spin is freaking dedicated to Jeff
Lang really and um yeah right there for
Jeff Lang um and all my other books are
dedicated to you know guys that I served
with that were killed but that book
it's dedicated to Jeff Lang and when I
told the story to kids I said he made a
little decision he made another little
decision he made another little
decision and sometimes you make
decisions they all add up but if you
make a mistake you can get back on track
but what I told the adults are what you
just said there's some decisions that
you make that you can't come back from
and I'll tell you what if you remove
alcohol and you remove drugs a lot of
those decisions ain't happen like in the
SEAL Teams we make the same joke in the
SEAL Teams
like different cultures of people like
if it wasn't for alcohol the seals would
rule the world you know cuz we just do
the dumbest stuff when we're drunk and
it's kind of true right dangerous I'm
sure me driving on the road and you guys
in regular civil like regular life of
being walking around like the things you
do are so extreme kind of like me on the
road I do extreme things but only in
that one little area so you guys in
regular life are prepared to do all
kinds of dumb things do some very big
dumb things that's for sure
is there some dumb thing fun story where
you're like I escaped death and I like
can't believe I did and that was so dumb
I mean just the amount of times of
getting in trouble and I I did always
have even when I when I drink I always
had like a little a little sick sense of
like it's time to get out of here like
grab guys like hey let's get out of here
I always had that so when I got in
trouble I I didn't really ever get
caught you know got very very lucky very
lucky doing dumb things you had an
ability to recognize something about
yourself that you realize is just
special and unique like you go this is
kind of the thing no no I I I'm a hard
worker that's okay that's I'm hard it
could honestly just be I know it's like
a little bit of a conflict but being
humble like like even like I just you
have so much humility like that is a
superpower in and of itself like the
SEAL Teams I realized I could work hard
and I realized that I needed to work
hard because I didn't have the natural
capability of some of the other guys and
so I just had to work really hard and I
was able to do that I was I can I can
put in some hours I can outwork people
that'll be my way of of winning is just
outwork them I want to go back just for
a second though to to to Jeff Lang and
to the scenario and when he told you
that like I I can't go to the
seals and you said no do you believe
that he had a pathway back at that
point for maybe but like he would have
needed to like go to rehab type
situation which is possible but I didn't
know enough at the time in my mind I
probably thought yeah you can get back
like dude just quit drinking and quit
doing drugs and go to a recruiter and
let's go you know but the reality of it
is probably he he' probably gotten in
trouble for drugs and because I can't
remember if he ever got like actually
arrested if you get arrested for drugs
like maybe they're not yeah so I
probably didn't know that at the time
yeah but I can't remember if he'd ever
been he might not have ever been
arrested which in which case yeah stop
drinking stop doing drugs get on the
path look there's plenty of guys that
are in the SEAL Teams that did all kinds
of crazy drugs and they cleaned up and
came in so there's plenty of guys have
been like that so yeah he actually yeah
he probably could
have I'm curious a little bit about um
war and like
being you know uh being at War like this
country's been at
War almost every year right and in in
hundreds of years of History it's
there's there's so many years of it and
what you think the right role for war is
war should be the absolute last option
that we ever
take unfortun we seem to take it as like
a door number two or three like oh well
and the reason we do that is because we
think we we're arrogant and we think we
can just go do what we want and we can
beat anybody and the reason we have that
arrogance is because it's true we if we
really wanted to win we can defeat any
military in the world in a conflict
there's there's no doubt about it we
just have
Superior technology we have Superior
training we have numbers like we could
make it happen the problem
is it's not going to be easy that's the
part that we trip up on it's not going
to be easy the enemy is going to get a
vote and what are we willing to
sacrifice for
victory and my common thing when I talk
about war is if you're going to war you
have to have the
will and the will that you have to have
is the will to kill and the will to die
and when you say the will to kill what's
hard about that is you don't just kill
the
enemy when you go to war civilians get
killed too and so you have to have the
will to do that you don't intentionally
do it but you have to recognize that
that is going to happen and then you
have to have the will to die which means
no matter how good you are you're going
to lose
troops so that takes both those things
takes a lot of will because the first
time America drops a bomb on a and
civilians get killed and they show a
bunch of pictures of civilians dead
because of what Americans dropping bombs
what does America do oh my gosh why are
we even doing this right so killing
innocent people why are we killing
innocent
people and then when our soldiers get
killed we say oh my gosh why are we
doing this we're losing our troops so we
go into Wars thinking we're not going to
have to kill anyone and we're not going
to have to kill anyone innocent or no
one innocent is going to die and we go
into Wars thinking that we're not going
to lose anybody and then when that
happens when those two things happens
which they do we start to try and figure
out why we're there and maybe we don't
need to be there so we go into Wars we
don't have the will to die we don't have
the will to kill which essentially means
we don't have the will to win which is
why Vietnam Afghanistan and Iraq
is that's pretty much what unfolded in
those
situations what creates someone having
the will to do those
things when you have to
win when you have an existential reason
to go to war so have we been
in not not needed Wars then oh yeah but
like World War II well what were we
going to do if we didn't win that war
the the world was to be a tyrannical
Place run by the Imperial Japanese and
the Nazis so we went in a war that we
had to win and therefore we sacrificed
hundreds of thousands of American troops
and killed hundreds of thousands of
civilians and we didn't bat an ey
because we had to win this doesn't
happen when you go into Afghanistan this
doesn't happen when you going to Iraq
this doesn't happen when you went when
we went to Vietnam and look there's
reasons that people rationalize why we
should do these things and those reasons
on the onset make sense oh we're going
to go into Vietnam because if we don't
stop communism from spreading in Vietnam
it'll spread throughout the rest of Asia
it's the Domino Theory it'll all become
Communists so it makes sense that we go
there and stop communism and that's
where it starts it pisses everyone off
and but it's a rationalization that can
be argued and you can say yeah I guess
that makes sense what they don't say is
hey
we should go into Vietnam to stop
communism from spreading and we are
willing to kill and we are willing to
die and we don't know what those numbers
are going to look like but you need to
put those numbers in a very big capacity
because you don't know how hard it's
going to be we think we're going to roll
in there and oh it's going to be no big
deal we have Superior weapons we have
Superior technology like I already
talked about but we don't realize oh the
superior technology doesn't matter when
you're fighting a a guy in Black pajamas
with an AK-47 that's hiding in a tunnel
your technology can't see him your
technology can't kill him so what do you
got to do you got to get in that tunnel
yourself now you're equal and then who's
gonna who's gonna care when they die we
killed millions of Vietnamese we bombed
them
into we eventually bombed them into
submission but it's kind of like when
England got bombed during World War II
their their will got stronger because
they when they got bombed they were like
oh actually we survived oh you bombed us
you bombed the hell out of us yesterday
there Nazis and we're still here their
will got stronger you have to bomb
someone to such an incredible level to
get them to say all right we need to we
need to figure out what to do that's
kind of what we did with the Vietnamese
we bombed them so they came to the table
and said all right let's make a truce if
this is where you start so yes these
things are are terrible and War should
be the last option and we should only
get into Wars that we have to fight and
we have to win so why do we go to so
many wars that we don't need then like I
said when you have people that
assess and they say oh this isn't going
to be that big of a deal like this isn't
going to take that long we we're far
superior and we have better military we
have better technology so we're going to
win so it seems like it's look they're
looking around like hey if we lose we
lose a couple hundred guys like it's
worth it because we'll get stability in
this in this area of
operations we lose a couple hundred guys
it's horrible but it makes sense because
think of what we'll gain strategically
and and that argument makes sense right
they they can they can articulate that
like hey we might lose a couple hundred
guys doing this doing this war but we'll
save more in the long run because of
this that and the other thing and so
people look at it they go yeah that
makes sense what they don't realize is
it's not going to be 100 guys it's not
going to be a thousand guys it's going
to be 5,000 going to be 10,000 in
Vietnam it's going to be
58,000
so we have leadership that doesn't
understand we have leadership that
hasn't been to war and they decide oh
we're going to roll in there and we're
going to put
Americans into body bags seems like uh
leadership of this country is like such
in question and I feel like we're
rolling into a year that's going to be
just really very interesting perhaps
scary aggressive um and and with the
election year like do you get into
politics at all does it serving our
country does it do you pay attention to
a lot are you do you get into it do you
have
opinions I I have definitely have
opinions
um but I I would say I don't get wrapped
up in the day to day
Mayhem that that goes on I I'm not
firing off political tweets I'm not
reading a bunch of political tweets and
saying oh my gosh how can they say that
because I know that everyone's got their
agenda that they're working on and
they're trying to make a statement and
they're trying to get retweeted like
there's a bunch of things like that
that's going on so I of course I deeply
care about the country I deeply care
about the direction that we move in but
I don't get wrapped up in like the
day-to-day uh Mayhem that's going on I
read the news every day I read the news
a couple times a day I get it from a
couple different sources and I always
want to know what's happening but I'm
not one of these people that's freaking
out about political situation every day
when you listen to the things that
different politicians say and people in
power like what do they say that
resonates with you in a positive way
like this is the way that the country
this is what I this is what needs to be
heard by everyone this is how the
country needs to be led this is what
someone should be saying when they're in
the place of power I I think that the
politicians that engage in the
day-to-day Mayhem that I just talked
about which is most of them it to me
diminishes like why are you thinking
about that right
now why why are you doing that why
aren't you thinking about the Strategic
direction of our country and they get
wrapped but that's part of America right
we're on a four-year election cycle
two-year election cycle in some cases so
for someone to get elected they've got
to be popular they've got to get the
sound bites they've got to get the
retweets that's what they're doing in
order to get a retweet you've got to
make it emotional for people so that's
why you say what you say and that gets
the retweets and that gets your
popularity and that drives up your funds
so it's all the system is definitely
pretty warped right
now does that make you sad like Ser
serving this like defending it with your
life and then going God it's like poorly
run you know or it's it's not this is
not the way it's supposed to be that
hurts you it it definitely bothers me
but America has been
through horrific situations we had a
civil war right we we had an actual
Civil War where we fought and killed
each other right and we got done with
that and were able to move forward um
late 60s early 7s like there was some
Mayhem in this country there were there
were police officers getting
assassinated in the streets like it was
a really there was bombings there was so
many bombings going on in the late 60s
early 70s look at every day and think
it's the worst it is now but when we
look at history there are there have
been some truly bad times so
we we will get through it now sometimes
do I think wait a second will we yeah
sure sometimes I think that but I also
think that when people like people ask
me if I would ever get involved in
politics and I say no never get invol
involved in politics
unless it got really bad and people will
I said that to someone someone's
interviewing me and now people go is it
bad enough yet is it bad enough yet is
it bad enough yeah I mean it's a
question I I will I have literally like
Jens done like all my podcasts I'm I
never talk about politics but for some
reason I'm getting pulled in and I don't
know enough like I'm not intelligent
Enough by any means I I and part of what
I'm curious about if I inter I
interviewed RFK long ago and you know
what I want to talk about a little bit
is
like what's the role of it why should I
be interested in it because I I'm not
but I'm getting pulled in and I'm and
I'm wondering you just said something
that is very interesting and maybe it's
because it's time maybe it's because
time for people that usually just kind
of get on with their life and try and
lead by example is there a reason like
there's a little bit of
a well as we start moving further and
further away from sanity people people
say hey shouldn't we bring this more say
when people ask me is it bad enough
isn't it bad enough right now I always
kind of respond like well you're writing
this on a cell phone from a cell phone
through a cell phone tower and has power
and there's energy and like you're in
Comfort your Frid is full like so
there's running yeah we're way far away
from where I got to get you've seen so
much worse if I'm getting involved in
politics it's like as a warlord right
it's like full on benevolent dictator
type scenario that's what I'll do but uh
but you do watch and I mean I watch and
I do pay attention and it is definitely
becoming increasingly disturbing the
what what politics looks like but again
as you just pointed out if you look at
politics throughout history there's
always been craziness going on there's
always been corruption and I'm not
saying that's okay but this is the way
it is is we've gotten through it before
we'll get through it again that's what I
believe most of the time I've often
thought to myself the people that you
would want to be your president or to
run the country there's so many people
you can think of that are like
really really like strong characters
great leaders humble great ideas Heart
Care um have like run giant companies or
grown businesses and you think you'd be
great for this country but none of them
would want the job why would no one want
the job that should have the
job well because the
job there's a lot of miserable
components of the job I mean I have a
lot of friends that are politicians uh
you know there's a bunch of congressmen
that are seal seals that are congressmen
became congressmen uh so I've got a
bunch of friends that are in that
business and man it's nasty it really is
it's just
nasty so I don't the way I look at it is
that's why and the only thing again when
you start talking about higher I think I
think congressmen can kind of run and
maybe it's not all about them once you
start running for like President you're
going to put up with so much more stuff
that the only reason in most cases
someone would run for president is for
their to to satisfy their own ego and
now we get back to the earlier
conversation which is such a dangerous
thing to have if you're trying to be a
leader yep it's very disturbing so
so we we'll see where it goes I I I do
think that there is a pendulum like
there's a giant pendulum for everything
and as that pendulum swings back and
forth and people get more people get
more crazy in One Direction it comes
back and right now like you could say
whether you're talking left or right the
pendulum is swung towards being extreme
in those two categories instead of
saying well the pendulum was on the left
and now it's swinging back to the right
I would like to think that the pendulum
is
Extreme and it's going to come back to
being more more Central instead of one
or the other it's more of a energetic
sort of like whoa it's all just a lot of
too contentious too divided let's get
more to Unity and hearing each other
listening y so I think the pendulum will
swim back in that direction I certainly
hope it will I just have one final
question uh and it might be hard to
answer because you're so humble but how
do you want to be remembered
uh how do I want to be remembered yeah I
hope I hope my kids remember I was a
good
dad I feel that one I feel that
one right off they will thanks jao thank
you appreciate
it thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe
button